oh baby the wait is over new dates added
on the middle class famous store gang
we're coming to see you bring the squad
out live stand up comedy show play a
little energy with the crowd great way
to introduce some people to the show
bring the squad out Kippy straighten
these bozos out the fat man ain't lying
folks uh this week we got Nashville and
indy and then in November we have two
shows in Atlanta as part of the red clay
Comedy Festival get those tickets then
we're going to Charlotte North Carolina
also we have a sold out show in
Philadelphia Two Sold Out shows in
Philadelphia sorry smell you next time
Philly uh Providence Rhode Island we
just had a second Show tickets available
in December Boston the same thing we had
in the second Show tickets still
available get those tickets those shows
will sell out we'll see you there see ya
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage blue show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we find
out the group to be classy yeah or just
a big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement she's upstairs burning
a meatloaf okay in the dryer which is
weird okay fair enough my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me
always a swinging a mess with the big
guest I feel like you're [ __ ]
throwing me under the bust on purpose
did it make any sense I tested well in
the focus groups whatever my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman he's my best
pal in the whole world and I love him
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan hey
what's up everybody please make sure
your rate of you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are
uh and then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com our garbage a lot of
that money check it the [ __ ] out yes sir
and gang we are sorely missing our good
pal T-Bone this week Gonna Fill in over
strike two for new guy Luke but he's
working the ones and twos first right
T-Bones out sick we wish you well buddy
hope you get better soon and we can't
wait to see you but give it up for the
Lower East Side Zone new guy Luke ladies
and gentlemen just happy to be here
but gang we could not be more excited I
mean not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guests here with us
today for the first time he is a
groundbreaking rapper songwriter and now
podcaster his albums include the hybrid
XXX atrocity exhibition you know what
I'm saying he has a brand new album
coming out and he also has 2013's old
which reached number 18 on the Billboard
charts baby
and he's the host of the Danny Brown
Show give it up for the one the only
Danny Brown baby
you guys are having me man thanks for
coming dude popped in on his way to the
airport with a rolly bag real classy too
came in with some muscle too this
[ __ ] guy came in it was you didn't
say anything until you dropped the bag
off which was weird you rolled in and
put the bag in the corner yeah I mean
you know you know came in correct I like
it buddy thank you so much for coming in
and sitting with us uh give us the back
story what's a Danny Brown story give us
the origin story
um pretty much yeah I don't know what's
going on out there somebody's yodeling
in the hallway
um pretty much born and raised in
Detroit Michigan
um I I had young parents okay my dad had
me at 16. damn my mom was 18. my dad's
half Filipino okay so I you know grew up
with that Community as well that was 16
usually the reverse I know right he's
pulling older abroads too shabby
18 year old
he had the long flowing hair
it's tropical man yeah he was you know
he was exotic back in those days you
know what I'm saying so yeah and you
know I mean it was great growing up I
mean because you know just even having
my dad in the house too because he put
me up on like all the music okay he was
super into house music like he's DJ
house sets and stuff like that but like
first it's like he's one brought me my
first Wu-Tang CD okay and stuff like
that to put me on so having some order
even like just video games you know like
I became a huge gamer because of my dad
oh cause he I got you because he was
younger and he was into it yeah he was
just putting you on the [ __ ] he liked
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] cool it was
dope it was dope so yeah so um brothers
and sisters I have two brothers two
sisters okay older younger I'm the
oldest you're the oldest all right yeah
that would make sense though they were
yeah that'd be weird
that's the crazy part I think about well
we have a like I have an older but
that's like an adopted sister type of
situation okay your parents adopted no
she my mom just to babysit her and her
parents got murdered okay so she just
took her in after that oh that's [ __ ]
awesome that's about as classy as it
gets right there murder into adoption
yeah so the good thing is I always just
just being around him and stuff showing
me rap music so I just always wanted to
rap and um like I like the first time I
ever heard rap music was um LL Cool J
Radio shout out yeah kindergarten I
remember my um my uncle picked me up
from school it was raining he's like man
hurry up I don't got time to be playing
with you today man we got to get to the
crib I got this new LL Cool J album
they're like what the [ __ ] you know
so I get to we get to the crib I
remember he pulls it out it's vinyl you
know what I'm saying pull it out he put
it on the plate and after the first two
808 hits I already knew what I wanted to
do I'm like I'm going to be a rapper
that's awesome so one day kindergarten
uh maybe Show and Tell uh-huh I didn't
know because I obviously wasn't paying
attention in class I guess and I didn't
have nothing to show or a tail but I
just went in front of the class and
raped you just make it up or were you
right no back then it's like the late
80s so it's still that old school like
hanging up at your mom's house
no doubling
my name is D in the place the Beast like
that you know stealing the sugar he'll
gang as best as you can yeah exactly
exactly but the teacher and all the
students you know at the Finish they all
went crazy so it was like oh crap and
then actually the uncle who actually
showed me the LL Cool J rack album I rap
for him one time just the look on his
face was like okay you didn't write that
and I was like no I didn't I just really
said it so ever since then I just kept
rapping it's like I don't know it's like
rap music I mean of course it saved my
life but it got me out of a lot of
trouble sure like even just like in
school or like I would always be kind of
quiet and I wouldn't tell people I know
how to do it but soon as I did it I'd be
like the most popular kids yeah next day
you know damn I mean it was it was like
having a [ __ ] superb
God damn even like when I was in jail
like everybody heard me rap in jail now
everybody's my friend now everybody's
nice all right we had coming up it was
the same thing as being like the funny
kid it's like it got you out of yeah
that guy's funny I don't [ __ ] with him
type thing you're like yeah I'm over
here just making knock knock jokes man
if I go in the can I'm [ __ ] yeah but
it gave me something around like a loose
joint it gave me so much confidence
though like self-esteems sure be able to
do that because it would be times where
I would like walk home from school and
like every drug dealer on the corner
would stop me and make me rap like give
me 20 give me a hundred dollars and
stuff like that really it was just I
don't know just at what age are we
talking there
um I would say that's about early high
school maybe okay listen all right side
gig yeah that's probably like 15 16
around that time what was the house
situation because of an apartment house
where we at my and were you in Detroit
proper yeah it was it was great because
my mom my mom's mom grandma she she
worked at Chrysler okay good job that's
a big deal in Detroit so um she bought
all our kids houses
that was the illness that's the
illustration somebody could did so what
did she do with Chrysler
I mean she worked on the line the
assembly line Cam and bought how many
houses did she have bought four four
houses holy [ __ ] that's what it used to
be back in the day though economy space
but this Detroit housing so who knows
they probably was 300 a piece or
something you know what I'm saying
so you walk in Beverly Hills out here
because she actually bought my mom a
real nice house on the east side so we
moved to the east side of Detroit and it
was so good about moving over there was
that um it was you know they had that
the bus situation of taking you to a
school into the suburbs kind of
situation okay coming to the hood and
get the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I put a go-to to a good Elementary
School that you know that was very
diverse I like how we play dumb on that
like I didn't know what you're talking
about so it was very diverse like even
on a situation like having like foreign
exchange students like I never even had
that [ __ ] yeah yeah that was crazy to me
like we had a guy from Mexico's code
name Ernesto he didn't speak one liquor
English he seen two episodes of The
Simpson he knew every word in the
English language
all right that's still going to be
talking like groundskeeper Willie all
day
we always thought that uh in the where I
grew up in The Burbs anytime we got a
foreign exchange student we always
assumed it was a cop
electricity
21 Jump Street 100 he's here to bust the
[ __ ] Knick back yeah we had some kid
that was like from Germany or something
like that and he wore uh like a weed a
weed leaf necklace
that's weird that's a that's you're
trying too hard yeah that one
um huh so School you went to school out
in The Burbs yeah you play any sports
pretty much on the um I wish I'll give
up all my rap Powers right now if I can
dunk
yeah but no I suck at sports man okay I
was never good I played a little
baseball I played baseball but yeah I
sucked I sucked I was only good at music
I was only good at music how are the
grades in high school uh oh I didn't get
any grades in high school I didn't I
stopped going to school did he dropped
out of high school I I would go every
day I just didn't go to class what would
you do about that understood where would
you hang out we just walking around the
hallways looking at other people classes
disrupting School how big was the school
Northwest I went to Northwestern High
School it's a pretty huge school but it
was pretty much like lean on me man it
was dice games on the roof hanging you
over it's [ __ ] selling Fried
Chicken in the hallway oh Jesus
um you can get a haircut in the bathroom
that's pretty classy
wait a minute I thought you said they
that the bus would pick you up and take
out no this is high school that was
elementary school so I went to high
school in the neighborhood you yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that was
backwards right yeah you show me these
tennis courts
throw the whole thing he wanted to go to
Northwestern though I wanted to I was
tired of the that type of school but it
did help me out because I had a teacher
there name is Capen and like I say with
the Reps you heard me rap one time in
any like School play or any anything she
can put me into rap she would throw me
in the rap damn so you would do that at
like an assembly or whatever I read that
my fifth grade graduation
I know like what did you bring the house
down I mean I think that was the first
time my mom and dad seen me do it in
front of people like that and he was
just like proud of me real so it's so it
was always like encouraged like my my
dad would buy me like little studio
equipment stuff and it was like I always
knew what I wanted to do sure in the
beginning I was like I don't need a
diploma for that [ __ ] yeah so once I got
to school once I got this like high
school was old enough messing around
with girls and stuff I just stopped
going to class so yeah I pretty much did
you not did you graduate or not graduate
no I can grad and graduate I still went
every day though really yeah I mean I
guess what else are you gonna do all
your friends did you go the last day of
school this episode sad
I felt like a loser I know Fried Chicken
always pretty good getting a shape up
before in history what are you talking
about I felt like a loser living the
[ __ ] dream I felt like a loser though
same school I'm saying just know I'm
saying all my friends graduate yeah and
now I'm like ah [ __ ] up man I'm a
loser so I might be garbage I might be
garbage anything about going back and
getting your you know diploma or GED or
anything or at this point you're like
[ __ ] it I never understood that of
people who become successful and they go
back I'm like I'm gonna graduate college
or whatever they suck my dick I don't
know why Michael Strahan's doing all
those TV shows he's got the NFL money
what are you throwing but I was I I
could tell you A big drastic thing that
happened to me when I was in school
which changed everything because I was
good in school and getting good grades
and stuff but I caught pneumonia in
third grade okay and I was out of school
for maybe like months it was months
I down there died so um but at that time
we were learning multiplication you know
and you miss a couple months Danny boy
you like the threes we were just we was
learning the threes by the end when I
come back they already doing Division
and [ __ ] and she didn't walk me back and
catch me up and help me with everything
so I was always so I was just [ __ ] up
from there and the feeling of sitting
there when you're like dude the whole
world is passing me by and I'm seven
years old this [ __ ] sucks I had that
and didn't get was that our Fred ammonia
I remember when they pulled out that
Texas instrument calculator okay I was
like I'm done with this there's no way
I'm moving forward I was pretty good up
until the tens and then when you get to
the 11 and 12 multiplication I was I'm
still kind of [ __ ] lost no so imagine
if you don't know multiplication now you
got to take algebra yeah
[ __ ] so I was starting to get I started
to get bad grades then and then one
literally it was just literally because
I didn't know [ __ ] and I was trying you
know I flunked algebra two yeah and I
was there for the multiplication games I
learned at all somebody explained this
to me in apples what are we doing here
let's go damn
um what uh what'd your parents do for a
living
um [ __ ] my mom just watched us my dad he
would have like odd jobs all the time I
feel like okay but I think for the most
party price so drugs
because he'll just pop you in and out
every blue moon you'll just see them
sleep on the couch and then he'll be
gone for like a month he'll pop back up
did they uh do they still live uh in the
same house no no we lost that house okay
we lost it that's the [ __ ] up part
every every on all all my grandma houses
they all eventually got you know
destroyed oh man damn just the economy
man yeah yeah man that's tough what was
the name of the street that that house
was on though blenders Flanders Street
Road what was it Lander Street yeah
Flanders what's good
from Flanders and Gratiot okay they were
all like like Detroit style like the
cookie cutter houses they were all no we
had actual big house yeah like the
biggest house on the Block I know I know
what type of house you're talking about
we ain't no we had an ale basement all
that [ __ ] really yeah really you're not
the grandma that's [ __ ] awesome I
feel bad because I felt like once I
started making money if I was really
smart I should have just bought the
house and fixed it back up bought the
house I just let it go I mean I bought
my mom a new house there you go let's go
come on I'm trying to lure Us in with
this sad story
that's that's [ __ ] real rappers I
don't know algebra either who gives this
[ __ ] but I'm saying like that's been
bawling just to see my childhood home
like being [ __ ] boarded up and [ __ ]
up now it's kind of sad yes that's that
is shitty for sure huh bought your mom a
house not too shabby was that the first
big purchase or was that after you kind
of got yourself straight a little bit no
I bought my house first
I moved around with me she lived with me
for a minute okay because but she didn't
like living with me though I mean I
guess it's just an ill Dynamic now you
know that it was a sure like I don't
want to live with you man my own [ __ ] So
eventually you know after I got my cars
and [ __ ]
because I know I had I mean Detroit is a
dangerous place man so I had to get
myself put myself far up away in the
suburbs is that where you you moved to
the burbs in Michigan I went to
Farmington Hills okay we did a show in
Ferndale not too long ago yeah all right
what's the name of the grocery store
when you were a kid that you guys went
to the Piggly Wiggly the good old Piggly
Wiggly that name
and someone from the East Coast that's
like a crazy name for a grocery store
the Piggly Wiggle but I guess it's so
popular yeah yeah and did you guys what
was the Chinese spot and what was the
pizza place growing up Chinese spot see
that's a New York thing for sure we got
Coney Island Coney Islands that's our
most that's the Detroit thing just Coney
Island we've all raised on Chilean
Vernors that's it
okay Coney Island Hot Dogs yes like yeah
hot dogs but wait there was no Chinese
restaurants in here they are Chinese
restaurants but they're very few in
between
it's like a big deal when you get
Chinese food you know I guess here yeah
that's the [ __ ] up part too of the
neighborhood I grew up in did you buy a
Little Caesars that's what I would have
done I get that first big check tell
your mom she's gotta wait till you get a
Little Caesars and a Papa John's under
here franchise and babe this rap ain't
gonna last forever I promise I'm gonna
loot back for you but yeah let's see I
grew up Born and Raised on Little
Caesars damn how many times a week we
talk that's a tough look it was a lot we
ate a lot of [ __ ] little Seasons
I don't know how it was so cheap
because they weren't a lot we're both
from the East Coast there wasn't a lot
of round where I grew up so like when we
did see one or you go over someone's
house and they had it and they had that
square box when they had to square it
felt like I was in a [ __ ] phenomenal
it was like a Sizzle Pie almost it was
fantastic now they do that hot and ready
round [ __ ] [ __ ] everything up it's so
cheap and nasty man yeah it sucks I love
the crazy bread still I still go get the
crazy crazy over there okay what's your
favorite fast food if you go
and do you eat it now I mean I still eat
fast food every blue moon I am garbage I
ain't gonna lie yeah but I would
probably say my favorite fast food is
White Castles whoa that's a first I know
right
that [ __ ] will take me out for two three
weeks I know a little white castles
though it's hard for me to not see a
white castles and not get none of them
they actually make good ass breakfast
sandwiches now really I've heard rumors
but the White Castle's breakfast
sandwiches are fire really yes sausage
egg and cheese man shout out to it right
how's I always wonder how's
Chick-fil-A's have you had Chick-fil-A
breakfast yeah I like the little um they
make these like little chicken biscuit
mini thingies okay and you dip they got
this ill-est spicy sriracha sauce now I
know that they're doing Chick-fil-A does
good with the sauces they really suck
with sweet Sriracha that's what it's
called it's like a sweet Sriracha it's
so [ __ ] good I'm in with that baby
well you get little white castles that
are in uh the frozen food section
ones yes
you still do that you can actually make
those almost cool
man get out of here you can actually
make those clothes too with a real White
Castle three minutes in an air fryer
they're delicious that just shows you
how bad White Castle is that you can
kind of do it at the house true
um we are Crystal Light family growing
up my grandma drink a lot of Crystal
Light really definitely yeah I hate that
[ __ ] though really no that's I mean
there's no sugar in it right true very
true what was the drinks at the house
you were sitting down with dinner would
you drink soda would you drink milk
would you we grew up on Faygo yeah
and if anything I say I say burners
burners is always a big deal um the
Faygo has a line of products
a million different flavors yeah they
have like the red the green that's you
know they have a cola though yeah yeah
Cola and you call it pop yeah we call it
pop call it pop
so Faygo yeah if they got crazy they got
a flavor called Rock and Rye like what
the [ __ ] is rock and rock but it sounds
good [ __ ] sounds like there's whiskey in
it but it's good as [ __ ] yeah
did you just feel your diabetes creeping
up every step you know what I'm saying
they got a moon Miss I love the moon
Miss
uh here it's out of this world that was
a bad joke but I had to make it um
okay first concert
first concert ever what seed going
backyard y'all doing good my first
concert my dad took me to see LL Cool J
and Run DMC at the Pine Knob theater
damn what year was this this had to be
late 80s late 80s [ __ ] and he said soon
as like um you know because Pine Knob is
like an outdoor theater where you sit on
the grass you can watch and he said as
soon as soon as the concert started I
wasn't even paying attention I turned
around to him and just started rapping
so I was performing and the crowd was
going crazy seeing this little kid like
just mimicking whatever he was doing on
stage so I wasn't even paying attention
to the show I was trying to be the show
that's awesome I know right
all right Kip how about that bespoke
post oh we love that box of awesome baby
awesome baby let's go it's the fall it's
pumpkin season it's outdoor season
outdoor grilling a lot of people like
the grill in the summer Grill in the
fall it's too hot in the summer you need
a nice breeze over a nice steak a baked
potato cold beer out there on a nice
fall day with the leaves are falling the
kids are yapping inside she won't shut
up you're losing it but you're out there
with a nice T-Bone getting nice got a
mold of cocktail going two something
sugar spice and everything nice get
outdoor grill where you get home group
you can get uh grooming stuff travel
stuff travel stuff cool guys stuff cool
guys
for the past three years cool guy [ __ ]
guys
um they sent us they just sent me a new
duffel bag too really I don't know
what's going on it keeps sending me [ __ ]
I come home every [ __ ] month I got a
box of cool [ __ ] I've been using this
gifts
getting clout with the fam guys to get
started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com here this is going to help
them pick the right box of awesome for
you they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
each box is valued at around 70 dollars
but you only pay a fraction of that
price there you go um plus with box of
awesome you're supporting small business
ninety percent of everything that comes
in your box of awesome it's from a small
up and coming brand it's free to sign up
you can skip a month at any time or
cancel to get 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the code garbage at
checkout that's box of awesome.com code
garbage for 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com code garbage do it can't let
me tell you about raycons raycon let me
tell you about those raycon earbuds all
right you know I like to use the uh I
had the the other brand sure for a
little while I want to talk about them
raycon sent us over a couple of pair all
right I threw them in one day because I
forgot the expensive ones yeah pop them
in got to juggle around listen to this
listen to that to different sounds
different kinds of music not too shabby
I gotta say and one of our boys took a
pair home because he was in a pinch and
he loves them yeah and they're a
fraction of the cost fantastic raycon
gives you eight hours of play time in a
32 hour battery life in your little
piping bike down right kind of gives you
the same audio qualities other premium
audio Brands and half the prices the big
man said it's easy to see why raycon's
everyday earbuds have over 50 000
five-star reviews not bad for dude up by
the number talk about true to roof
that's cooking over there go to buy
raycon.com garbage15 today and use promo
code garbage 15 to get 15 off your
raycon order that's byracon.com
garbage15 with code garbage 15 to score
15 off by raycon.com garbage15 uh ah do
it do it that [ __ ] it's pretty good what
color uh what were the pets like growing
up any pets oh [ __ ] that's another
[ __ ] up story too cause my dad I gotta
say he had a whole bunch of very good
responses he had a whole bunch of drug
dealing friends and [ __ ] and I guess
when his friends just was Ill with
collecting a whole bunch of exotic
animals and [ __ ] so when he went to jail
my dad feeling like he want to be a real
[ __ ] he gonna take in all the pets and
[ __ ] so we growing up with [ __ ] 10
foot long pythons and [ __ ] and my mom's
are scared of everybody it had it
definitely had to cause some trauma in
all of us and also Imagine you [ __ ]
crazy you're in elementary school every
night you you might wake up Miss a
[ __ ] python in your bed [ __ ] that so
yeah we had crazy pythons Crazy Birds
yeah birds were they loose in the house
or were they in the cage python killed
the birds though what yeah we had like
man like a [ __ ] Jungle Book Jesus
Christ but then the fishes was extra
crazy too I like a nice fish we had like
ill red doubles I like that you said
fishes oh that yeah the fishes was lit I
did like
dumbass one time in school they gave me
you know you can get a frog they'll give
you a frog and I don't know what made me
think this I'm looking at the frog in a
little thing and I'm like he seems like
he'll be better off in the tank but his
piranhas and Red Devils so as soon as I
put them in there I'll just see them
like [ __ ] what are you doing he's
trying to get out yeah wait he brought
them you brought the Frog hitting them
from every direction boom boom next
thing there's lots of raptors it was
just a skeleton shape of a frog at the
bottom of the tank looked like
decoration like we did it on purpose I
think he's next to the scuba guy I'm not
getting the name of this class yeah tell
you that yeah so you got a frog from
school brought it home put in a piranha
tank and it was eaten yeah how did the
how did the python get at the birds oh
because see the python we would put him
in the um in the birdcage no he had his
own cage but after a while he started
sneaking out so we'll put like weights
and [ __ ] on top of it so I never trust
that dude over someone's house and they
have a big snake there's like books and
[ __ ] get a proper [ __ ] lid that they
can't oh yeah so he will sneak out every
night and you'll hear the weight
spoiling
brother Mark he was the only one that
wasn't really scared of it so she'd be
like Mark get the snake and he'll just
he'll go find it whatever [ __ ] but one
time yeah he um
no actually what happened was he was
trying to get at the pier keep and from
whatever she killed herself by mistake
trying to get away from right into the
wall or something yeah yeah it's suicide
don't look at a goddamn snake yeah so
yeah that was my pet situation parakeet
shot itself that's crazy
what would you do for lunches during
school when you were a kid would you
pack a lunch would you buy a lunch no I
was on welfare
you got three weeks at school yeah how
was the school lunch at school I loved
all the free lunches especially the
McRibs the fake McRibs used to have yeah
one bizarre item we did have there a lot
of people always had those man they
don't they used to have these burritos
with a hot dog in it though whoa burrito
I was a hot dog huh huh was there like
was it a tortilla yes it was a you know
it's wrapped tortilla like a burrito but
it'll be like a hot dog in there with
like some type of taco meat sauce
situation going on I love those I don't
care that doesn't sound too bad yeah we
had something similar called a Texas
Tommy which was a hot dog with cheese in
it wrapped in bacon in a regular hot dog
bun oh yeah I was just telling these
guys because Coney Island was you know
as I said that was our food spot but
they had things called fish dogs okay
fish stick it was just like a fish Patty
on a hot dog hot dog bun you could get
it for like a dollar fifty it was great
I don't hate it do you like a filet of
fish at Mickey D's will you throw
another one of those I love those I
bought two of them and stack them
together oh that's not bad [ __ ]
gentlemen over here real fishy man
because they're a little too though
okay well you brush your teeth in the
shower yes pee in the shower yes do you
keep the toothbrush in the shower yes
whoa okay garbage will you fart in an
Uber huh will you fart in an Uber I'm
farting everywhere I've been coming it's
coming
I'm doing is holding it man you can die
from holding first can't you that's what
my grandma told me back in the day
Grandma said you could die from holding
the park man so I'll hold if I let him
go the other day I farted loud as hell
in front of a girl at the airport man
you look on her face was just horror
like what are you doing I'm like man I'm
living on a plane yesterday like crazy a
plane you can get away with it a little
bit if it had a blanket over me so I
felt like I had an extra force field
yeah and nobody can hear anything most
people have their headphones on and the
hum of the plane gives you a little bit
of coverage you kind of hope it doesn't
smell other than that you're all right
fingers start getting pointed at me real
quick you gotta drop them silent murders
man all right you can't push them too
hard man you got to let it seep I can't
airplane
where it's like crazy I think everybody
do it's hard I think everybody do
horrible when you were a kid you have a
BB gun or numb chucks or Chinese stars
or anything like that actually no my mom
wouldn't let us play with guns and stuff
like that the train was crazy at that
time like it was real and in the
neighborhood we grew up in wasn't the
you know wasn't the safest place so
didn't want your mouth she wouldn't even
let us yeah we would we couldn't even
roam the neighborhood she's like you go
in the backyard and that's it they
bought it bought us a basketball rim
played basketball come in the house and
play video games that's it so I will say
to my parents that was the smart thing
they did they would whatever we can
whatever they can get us that we was
into that would keep us in the house
with me with Studio [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying maybe get rid of the [ __ ]
alligator I know I know but but the cool
[ __ ] about that too though was one day
we let we we know everybody in the hood
you know the one that I just bring the
snake outside now I'm the coolest yeah
it's got snakes and [ __ ] like what the
[ __ ] going on in there I was always
afraid of a guy with a snake while just
walking he was huge too like literally
he was like man you had to go get him
the mice and [ __ ] for him to eat to feed
him some white mice yeah so [ __ ] so
crazy I don't like that it's scary
um have you ever washed your shoes in
the washing machine or the dishwasher
washing machine I'd definitely wash my
shoes in the washing machine that
doesn't work though someone could come
out all oblonged and weird and [ __ ] I
think that's like a thing you wanted I
think that's a kid that's a kid thing
yeah like let me put my shoes in the
washing machine but then they end up
making all types of noises
I don't know sounds like there's a brick
in there yeah yeah
so yeah I remember one time um I cleaned
some Air Force Ones I cleaned them with
some bleach but I didn't really get the
bleach smell out too much so now I'm in
school with my shoes just freaking like
bleach and my teacher's like oh my God
she's like oh no Daniel that's not good
we can't do this you sent me home over
that [ __ ] got sent home for Felicia yeah
because it was they smell really bad
though oh man it did seem like
something's not safe about this sure yes
go kill one of these kids I gotta open
Crackle window you wash one in Bleach
one in the money you can't cross
yourself and then they turned another
color you know they turned they were
white and then they turned to like a
yellowish
yeah yeah that was done I put bleach on
like stains on like shirts and it's
eaten through the shirt really yeah
I went straight hardcore with it
what's the credit score like Danny oh
it's all [ __ ] up
it's just real bad for a couple trying
my best man can you throw a number
I don't know man not good it's not good
it's not good love it what credit cards
do you have do you have an American
Express
Capital One yep discover no thank God
all right cool is the AmEx a black Amex
no [ __ ] no ain't that rich
that [ __ ] regular plastic
is it one of the green ones no it's a
gold all right
there you go that's funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a regular plastic they don't make
no noise
huh okay will you buy stuff at the
duty-free shop at the airport
cigarettes
walking out with a bunch of cartons you
get a couple cards before you get to get
to Europe or something what's your uh
smoke a choice Newports I'm black but
they don't sell new parts in the
duty-free they don't no you just got to
get like Marlboro Menthol whatever is
menthol what's the reasoning for getting
them other than maybe they're a little
bit cheaper getting them in in America
and not getting them in Europe why don't
you like the European ones European cigs
are different for sure plus they really
scare you with those pictures I just I
mean I just want to be prepared
that's crazy who does that a lot of
people that I used to do when I gotta
keep it fresh keep batteries in the
freezer the fridge that's some old
school hood [ __ ] right yeah I think
they're gonna come back yeah they never
do I used to put my Nintendo games in
the freezer really you have to blow them
to make it work yeah I remember that
good strategy was you put it in the
freezer for a minute let it get cold and
it'll work right right instantly dude I
never heard that that's probably why
they didn't work because they were
overheated yes it wasn't dust on the
inside I thought you were blowing dust
off you were cooling it down dude that's
pretty genius yes that's because you got
to think they have fans and [ __ ] in
there [ __ ] yeah I thought it was dust
this whole time no he was cooling it
down God I thought I lived in the
dustiest [ __ ] house in the in the
world yeah
have you ever saved a cigar box for
storage
I don't smoke cigars what you mean cigar
box what's a cigar box as a little kid
like a box of cigars come in I don't
know put like baseball cards I've never
even had weirdos before no they're like
cardboard yeah yeah I like the girls
though
have you ever saved a Crown Royal bag
for storage
I mean put change in yeah
let's change it might have a little weed
in here I think everybody's done that
everybody that's the only reason to buy
Crown Royal no man I know bags are all
right get my hand on one of those bags
maybe one of my friends took a took a
whole bunch of them and made a sweater
out of it it was amazing I've seen that
before I think I saw a robe on Instagram
it was fire
um when you did start making a little
bit of quiche what was the first crazy
big purchase hmm or any purchase you
still regret where you're like that was
or I mean I would buy a lot of stupid
ass clothes yeah when did you buy the
house like when did you buy your first
house
um I can't remember what year did you
pop off like what was your first year
you're like oh [ __ ] I'm a I'm a I'm a
I'm a successful triple X came out yeah
that was 2011. so I probably didn't get
a house about maybe 2015.
that's conservative that's smart there
you go I lived in apartments for a long
time okay before I really was like
[ __ ] out I need to get a house I
didn't think I could afford a house
what year did you buy your mom's house
um maybe like two years after maybe like
2017. okay cool is she still in that now
nice I sold my house when I moved to
Texas okay yes did you buy a new one
down there yeah nice
all right that's okay that's not too
shabby there
so I think the mama house is a big [ __ ]
is a very classy move what about the
cars what was the first first nice car
you bought
um of course Cayenne wow
[Laughter]
I was gonna say that's very Country Club
yeah yeah but at the end I got it okay
so I gotta tell you I don't know how to
drive you know how to drive you want a
Porsche you bought a Porsche and knowing
how to drive uh yeah I don't know how to
drive I've got a license yeah I do but I
finessed that situation
never make a left turn no it's actually
a Detroit is one of those ones you can
go to like I mean y'all call them DMVs
or whatever yeah yeah but you can go to
ones with like all the like uh migrants
go that don't really speak English so
you go to that one a bunch of numbers
yeah yeah it is and it's it's an actual
DMV and this is at the time I had like a
crazy ass Diamond Grill and [ __ ] so when
I showed up to take the driver's test I
just totally like man let me just give
you five thousand dollars to pass me man
he's like no I can't do that I can't do
that but six on his face I didn't
actually do the test I failed every part
of it they let you go but as soon as I
pull it back up to the to the to the
spot I'm like I just look at him and
smile you see the diamonds it's almost
like finessing the girl or something
yeah Rolly on all type of [ __ ] like yeah
how did I do okay did you hit the Pam no
damn I'm finessed him just a smile I
messed them yeah all right then I got my
driver's license and uh I got the
Porsche and I started trying to drive oh
I can't drive this [ __ ]
so I got me a Tesla after that now I got
more cars but honestly drives itself
yeah that's the only car I know to drive
I can't drive another car only car can
drive is a Tesla so I don't consider
myself knowing how to drive I think
that's what Elon Musk had in mind when
he created it I know I know and I got an
old one too like a 2013. we only got 30
000 miles on it that's how much I've
drove it I just dropped to the store and
back yeah so that's all you have now I
can't get on the freeway I don't know
how to drive on a highway yeah or take a
car I probably spent most of my money
but yeah I used to buy like [ __ ] two
thousand dollar jeans and [ __ ] right
yeah [ __ ] thousand dollar t-shirts
and [ __ ] just dumb [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] like
that you ever have any Ed Hardy stuff
[ __ ] no
that's what he thinks school is that's
how out of touch he is with any anything
ever I was wearing like Rick Owens and
like ball of mine and I don't even know
stuff like that yeah but that was my
dumbest biggest purchase this was buying
all them dumbass clothes okay you can't
keep you know they're really cool if you
can only yeah you can only you can't
like wear that every day for three years
like I wore it I wore a leather head to
toe for an entire summer who wears
leather in the southern Leather t-shirts
leather pants
it was cool
I look back at that I look back at that
face like what the [ __ ] was going on
that was definitely like some mere life
crisis [ __ ] like man you was 35 years
old
yes looking like a baseball club man I
really did look stupid wearing biker
jeans and [ __ ] that was a bad phase it
was a bad face oh man I thought I was a
rock star yeah I mean you kind of were
you were you know very successful
musician you know rapper yeah leathers
and [ __ ] that was my [ __ ]
um you flying first class
um not these days
yeah but other than that no I don't do
that [ __ ] no more will you take your
shoes off on the plane I gotta take my
socks off on that [ __ ]
toes me out man she put me in coach I'm
gonna act like it yes
I'm gonna go get some booze I'm a booze
up real good so I could be sleepy get on
the plane take my toes out and pass out
damn will you bring food on the plane
from outside like the from that point
it's a real that's garbage that's real
bad I got your toes are out and you're
like nah the burger McDonald's is
McDonald's smells crazy once you get in
the area smell man it smells I'm so mad
but I used to do that though I used to
give a [ __ ] especially like the fish
fillets especially if I'm doing like an
overseas flight or something I'm coming
on the plane with a Big Mac you know
what I'm saying and it smells horrible
man yeah it's no good the house you have
now shoes off in the house yeah we live
in Texas man it's hot I thought I wear
sandals now no I don't like shoes no
more if we come over if we came over to
the house no you keep using keep your
shoes on I ain't got carpet I just buy
hardwood [ __ ] all my kids Bernard wood I
don't think I don't [ __ ] with carpet
it's the smartest thing I've ever heard
in my life I don't [ __ ] with carpet get
all Hardware like the first house that I
did but I had I remodeled it and it paid
twenty thousand dollars just to get
[ __ ] hardwood floors because it was
carpet in there I'm like take all this
carpet out I mean not pretty sweet I
know what you mean though yeah of course
I already did it sweet but it worked out
good for when I sold it so
investment
Kim Let's talk about butcher box baby
put your box put your box
of that one of our faves we love butcher
box we like having a freezer uh-huh full
of top Quality Meat grass-fed grass
finish wild caught wow we were just
talking about grilling before it's the
perfect time of year to grill and what
are you going to use you're gonna get
steaks from the grocery store I was in
there because you spent a weekend in
Chernobyl butcher box lines up with top
quality meat it's unbelievable we love
it yeah you got a weed guy you need a
meat guy yes
butcher box has a special offer for our
listeners we love them they love our
listeners it's a it's a Love Fest over
here butcher are you guys ready butcher
boxes all free here we go butcher box is
offering new members two free New York
strips and eight ounces of cold crack
Lobster in your first box plus ten
dollars off they're giving
laptopsis
we're gonna get in trouble we're gonna
come down from the top put your box
Lobster is wild caught by independent
Harvesters in the North Atlantic then
pressure extracted from the claws and
Knuckles so you get the most delicious
succulent what you've ever tasted this
is funny let me tell you this you know
what I'm thinking you make a move on
that now you keep them in the freezer
you're ready to go New Year's Eve around
the holidays Thanksgiving got good stuff
there New Year's what are you talking
about you sign you sign up you get it
you have it you love it you have your
wife sign up it keeps coming worked
assist no new members though you got new
members put your box takes the guesswork
out of finding high quality Meat and
seafood 100 grass-fed free range organic
chicken whole nine yards you mainly
raise no antibiotics no other hormones
as we've said it ten thousand times we
love the [ __ ] out of butcher box I got
ground beef coming out the Wazoo sign up
today at butcherbox.com
uh Slash ayg to get two 10 ounce New
York strip steaks and eight ounce of
lobster corn and knuckle me free and
you're I'm serving under up under
another name I know cool guy getting my
hands on it plus ten dollars off your
first box that's butcherbox.com ayg do
it bam uh anyone in your family still
have an AOL email address
I don't even think anybody in my family
know how to use it I swear to God
straight hood [ __ ]
you ever wear suspenders
um as I'm pretty sure I had some as a
kid I'm pretty sure I had some of the
kids I mean not by choice I'm pretty
sure my mom put me on that dumb ass [ __ ]
okay sure not as an adult though no no I
wouldn't wear suspenders unless I want
to be freaky with no shirt on that just
got him to cover my nipples yeah
I want to get freaky
go up that [ __ ] on my nipples
okay uh
will you get cash back when you're
making a purchase no never do that I'll
never do that yeah that's weird it's
yeah it's trashy it's real trash is it
yeah people don't do it to try to avoid
the you know surcharge or the fees or
whatever it's also like just I don't
know ten dollars back at CVS yeah that's
weird to me no I don't do garbage I
don't do that do you shake your drinks
when you drink them like if you have
like something where you're shake it up
for it [ __ ] no what about the orange
juice in the fridge at the house I don't
drink orange juice
[Laughter]
what's in the fridge now we go over to
your house what do you know hey thanks
for coming Kevin and Henry what do you
want do I have Sparkling Waters really
yeah I just drink Sparkling water all
day that's good all right Lacroix what
are you rocking um no and um Texas they
have one called Rambler okay we have a
brand called Rambler I love that [ __ ]
isn't Topo Chico real big yeah
all right and the glass bottles you get
one of those you get one of them crispy
cold
thank you
you have a give a grill at the house a
grill yeah with ribs and [ __ ] no like
yeah do you have a grill yeah I got a
Traeger oh yeah I love I make ribs every
weekend I'll be burning them up sometime
when I get drunk though I'll be
forgetting what's the drink of choice
the booze wise I've been I've been
drinking whiskey lately yeah but I think
tequila is probably my number one I
think it was my favorite I mean it's the
healthiest I feel like I don't feel like
if I'm drinking tequila I don't really
have too many like crazy hangovers and
[ __ ] like that yeah Patron and a little
Topo Chico with a little bit of lime not
too bad but whiskey been [ __ ] my
stomach up so I think I'm about to
switch back a lot of sugar and whiskey
they say hmm you play any God Kevin I'm
sorry you know how to use chopsticks
[ __ ] no okay
you like Korean barbecue love it what
are you talking about Koreans make the
best fried chicken yes they do I know
that
they really do man I know that for a
fact what uh what's the air freshener in
the car in the Tesla air freshener
that's a good question and do you smoke
in the car no I don't smoke in my car
all right but no no I don't think I even
have a hair first you get the car wash
on the regular yeah you do I do do that
inside and out yeah I do do that nice
you smoke in the house or you go outside
not cigarettes I smoke cigarettes
outside cigarettes outside okay that's
pretty close gentleman answer yeah I got
I got a nice garage where I set a nice
little smoking setup there you go how
many car garage is it oh it's the
one-car garage one car garage
car outside you turn into like a little
little man cave yeah I got my Muay Thai
bags up and stuff okay you got chairs or
a couch or what is this coach a few
couches in there one step from putting
the TV out there I swear to God one
thing that's what I've been spitting
because I spend most of my time out
there yeah dude smoking cigs on a couch
in a garage
it's all I need man that takes this [ __ ]
up that's all I need let me ask you this
you're driving in the Tesla you're
running to the store
if you pass a speed trap will you
flicker your lights to let the other
drivers know that there's there's a cop
up ahead no no that's snitching
no you're yo you're warning the
yeah but you're still snitching on the
police
that's pretty good that's ditching man
snitching snitching yeah you got to
figure it out yourself
you got to figure it out yourself it's
every man for yourself out here this is
Royal Rumble I can't even drive you're
taking the heat off of me yeah I don't
have a license
like Royal Rumble man damn do you know
anybody at all in any of your circles
that have been a customer on Bar Rescue
what is Bar Rescue oh to one show when
they go in there and they fix the bars
up and [ __ ] yeah no definitely not you
watch Pawn Stars or Dog the Bounty
Hunter I watch 90 Day Fiance yeah
I like 1998 fiance and I like um Love
Lockdown you play any games after
lockdown yeah do you play any games on
your phone like Forge of Empire or
anything like that no I got a steam dick
what's a steam deck in my bags the new
video game console is [ __ ] like a
switch it's it's
what's your favorite game what are you
playing uh I've been playing power wash
simulator
the [ __ ] is that power wash simulators
you start a power washing business oh my
God hire you the power wash [ __ ] it's so
relaxing it's actually a very soothing
relaxing ass game that's the craziest
answer I've heard forget about the
snakes forget about the Piranhas forget
about the haircuts in school that's the
trashiest thing
Blue Collar video games yes that's crazy
it's so fun dog it's so fun too I've
I've had a landscaping business on Xbox
I was literally uh power washing
somebody's backyard like their Dexter I
gotta get back but the thing is it's
like I'm 99 but I can't find where the
rest of the dirt at the clean so I don't
know you know like why am I 99 on this
man like the lady at the house is coming
out and yelling at you I gotta go watch
some YouTube tutorials or something I
will say this in your defense
there is an Instagram Trend sure power
washing therapeutic it's you know man
when you watch them clean those that is
pretty good I get it but the fact that
you've started a business and you're
like you know yeah
other people hire you to go power wash
it how's the business doing uh like I
say I'm stuck on 99 on this one [ __ ]
patio and power washing his patio for
days God damn algae
we're watching this vicious
is my favorite sentence dude that's my
favorite sentence ever I do good with
the cars like the cars but once you
start putting me in like residential
neighborhoods man it's like what the
[ __ ] is going on
that one easy man but when you got to do
the backyards man it's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
with some like little dirt under the
table or something like that man so so
what you can't stop until you're not
until you're 100 you can't move on to
the next job oh man yeah that sucks I'm
stuck on this [ __ ] place on Google I
was gonna say his Yelp ratings The Rock
Bottom man that's what I think video
games are changing into like playing
games doing [ __ ] you would do in real
life like oh yeah all simulator nobody
wanted I wouldn't wanna watch it in real
life you know what I'm saying but that's
a video game it's kind of fun uh ever
taking an old-timey photo like where
you're dressed up as Cowboys or anything
like that
I dress like a cowboy for like a whole
year when I first moved to Texas you and
Tony Tony yeah man Tony that was my boy
he's together all the time right so yeah
I dress like a cowboy the entire time
but it made me realize it was kind of
dangerous because when I started to be
around like Mexican cartel looking
[ __ ] they'd be like who you
work for like what you mean who I work
for
[ __ ]
sir please
so y'all stop dressing like that because
it felt dangerous it felt dangerous okay
uh here's the hypothetical if you were
at a baseball game and you were out in
the Outfield and you caught a home run
and there was a kid next to you would
you give it to the kid or would you keep
giving it to the kids ain't that garbage
man there you go
I hate seeing [ __ ] like that yeah [ __ ]
drives me crazy anyone in your family
Ever represent themselves in court
probably not by choice
yeah yeah probably not by choice but he
didn't like the looks of the public
defender yeah
I'm pretty sure this is the bozo you
give me no no no I got this yeah I'm
pretty sure do you have a do you have a
cleaning lady at the house now in Texas
of course you come through every other
weekend you come through every weekend
will you will you clean up and tidy up
and yeah of course you get there yeah
yeah you do yeah but my house don't even
be that nasty anyway it's just
my girl refused to clean she's one of
those she's not a clean lady I'm with
you she's not a cleaning lady so she'd
be like [ __ ] that car cleaner lady call
her cleaning but I'm I'm super clown I
pretty much do all the house [ __ ] keep
it tight yeah got a Roomba put the room
down
if you have a Swiffer you have a Swiffer
nice oh no we got an eel we just bought
a it's like a steamer type of situation
I know exactly what you're talking about
yeah and it's smoke everywhere and it
cleans the floor yeah it used to be an
infomercial those in the 90s I was
obsessed with it was called like the
shark or something but if you make a
mistake and hit your foot with that [ __ ]
oh my God that shit's so [ __ ] hot man
this thing your skin hanging off man
um who's doing it you do the laundry
if I'm not in a doghouse
if you're not in the doghouse yeah but
I'm always standing in a dog house one
foot in one foot out but if I'm not an
adult that's how I know when I'm being
good when she start washing my clothes
okay but most of the time but if you're
in the doghouse you're washing your own
clothes yeah or laundry detergent you're
using uh whatever she bought oh she
bought that [ __ ] um
what's the name of it game tied like no
like a like a like some some [ __ ]
Trader Joe's type [ __ ] man
oh wow it's not even a brand you can get
from like a normal [ __ ] store and
[ __ ] it's like Piggly Wiggly peppermint
smelling [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
okay what about the soap in the shower
what are you using there using a bar
using body wash yeah I use a bar I use
uh my favorite soap is a um it's a
lemongrass tea tree soap whoa Mr Danny
Brown for your skin and [ __ ] like it
gets harder like all right like you know
sure [ __ ] like that yeah any loofah you
do bars bar skin I'm straight bar
straight bar skin okay that's what I'm
always itching and [ __ ] I'm born
do you floss every day
um I got a um
I got [ __ ] veneers so I have to nice
when'd you get those
um maybe a few years four years ago
something like that a couple of bucks on
that 30k Jesus Christ my Keeper's really
[ __ ] up though really yeah so it
didn't it just wasn't that they had it
feel that that they're you know or is it
just normal after a while it just became
normal at the world I think damn 30k you
got to pay that all at once what's the
deal no I think it was increments okay
pretty much went through like oral
surgery like they would they was telling
me when you come take two Xanax because
we about to do some [ __ ] and it's oh my
God I got a dentist yeah it was so bad
too like it was so bad too like I'm I'm
not even gonna lie so you have implants
you have like the the rods I have no
teeth they're sharp though I'll tell you
that and you're set for you're set for
life with them right yeah you got to
take care of them though like going to
the dentist all the time like right now
I need to go to the dentist I know
because you know a lot of food and [ __ ]
get cut up that you can't get out of
here and they gotta go in there and take
them out and clean inside of there and
it's so nasty but they do they take them
out and clean them oh man just to hear
that drill like all right it's got to
feel good though I'd love to have my
teeth taken because I think it's screws
yeah
so hot
Brown yeah my teeth was my teeth was
really bad
hmm you know anybody who had a
breathalyzer in their car
I think of them now yeah yeah um like in
Texas when you get DUIs they make you
put the breakfast in there yeah yeah my
homie my homie um he got one of his car
and he can't start it up until you blow
yeah but he just put me up on game he
said do you want to be breathalyzer you
just got to keep peanut butter in the
car I've heard that too I heard peanut
butter is under the mouth or whatever
yeah
I don't know if this is the guy to be
trusted he's got one in the car he
clearly hasn't passed every single one
of them and he caught a DUI coming from
Kill Tony I'm like how unlucky are you
about to kill Tony he's a great show so
why did that peanut butter all over your
mouth
um what's the mayonnaise situation in
the house do you do mayonnaise
you do mail I mean I don't already do
Miracle Whip yes maybe that's both I
think we got both in the crew you have
Miracle Whip yeah I think we got both
but I I don't like um I don't I don't
think we use I don't feel like we eat
Mayo we don't mess with it too much my
favorite Mayo is the Burger King I like
Burger King's meal
that's a that's a very specific taste
you know the long chicken sandwich
and I'll say this I love that chicken
sandwich that's the best chicken they
can kick rocks with they're trying to go
up to the Popeyes they try to go to
Chick-fil-A stay in your lane those long
ones are bad oh yeah yeah the long
chicken sandwich is the best the best
that saved my life anytime you are out
of when you go overseas and [ __ ] you can
go get it yeah yeah sure all the time
yeah fast food here is pretty good with
heavy Mayo
okay all right what's your favorite
flavor Gatorade
um
gotta be that Vince Carter one what the
[ __ ] is that one remember Vince Carter
had his own Gatorade flavors I think it
was called like Raptor Punch or
something like that it was purple the
Vince Carter Gatorade man
Vince Carter Gatorade commercial yeah
it was so good that one was so good man
okay all right so good that's the first
time we ever got that [ __ ] answer
yeah I don't know why they just
continued it they should have kept that
[ __ ] going the first Raptor yeah Coffee
Guy you drink coffee
I think it comes it comes and goes comes
and goes you don't make it in the house
yeah yeah sometimes like I'm saying
sometimes I'm drinking coffee and I'm
drinking a [ __ ] ton of coffee every day
all day and then sometimes I'm just not
drinking coffee for like months are they
pods or is it a pot I got the Keurig
[ __ ] you know but my girl she got the
fancy old espresso all that [ __ ] she
looks at me like you're disgusting you
got that at the crib yeah the machine
[Music]
really yeah so that's a little bit of
cash
I mean she's a esthetician ah wait is
that the Hair Botox and [ __ ] well
there's some cash in that too what is uh
what's the couch situation in the living
room you got a sectional yeah sectional
leather no that's um a little soft I
don't know what that material would be
called it's a regular couches yeah yeah
like you can draw you can draw on it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay you can draw on it you can draw on
it if you will I'll be tagging and [ __ ]
Danny wants you know I know what you're
talking about with your fingernails yeah
yeah
change the direction of it yeah yeah
Central AC I assume in the house of
course it's 100 degrees every day
you got a pool at the house [ __ ] no okay
do you ski or uh snowboard [ __ ] no when
was the last time you ordered Dave and
Buster's
um probably a few years ago okay yeah I
remember yeah I was hanging out with
Ashley Nico and we went to Dave and
Buster's a good time all right would you
ever go skydiving everybody says it's a
life-changing experience but I don't
need my life change I'm happy with the
way things are going
amen I respect Amen on that yeah uh have
you ever wore a kangal hat hell yeah
where can goes
recently oh no I'm not recently growing
up like yeah I appreciate I mean if I if
I did thousands I wanted one I
definitely wanted one yeah the bucket
hat the king oh that look Jose bucket
hat yeah of course yeah the purple one
didn't even have a purple one I have to
get everything yeah I remember the
purple one every color
um what's the vacation situation you
guys go on vacations I don't not a big
vacation guy because I mean just after
you know touring so much flying like me
getting on a plane is I got to be
getting paid to be doing that [ __ ] I
ain't getting on the plane just to have
fun never been to Disney World
Disneyland no none of that [ __ ] okay but
I thought about it I'm gonna take my
girl to Disneyland or something like
that but my girl she always want to go
she she gets to the point she'd be like
oh you're not gonna go out take a trip
by myself and she'll go to [ __ ]
Mexico or something okay all right
that's not bad I like that have you ever
been to Mall of America yeah of course
yeah you like it
um they got the comedy got a cool comedy
club in there yeah there is one yeah
House of Comedy I think I say Andrew
centino there yeah
um
we take leftovers home from a restaurant
yeah why not okay but not all the time
it depends on what it is like certain
[ __ ] you know just ain't gonna come back
right uh-huh you know so yeah I ain't
taking it yeah I'm anti-left over like
I'm not taking french fries home from a
restaurant like what are you doing right
now I'm taking a cheeseburger and
surprise like come on man yeah yeah eat
that [ __ ] there if you go out with a
group of people you know four or five
friends will you get apps for the table
or do you prefer to have individuals off
the table you like it for the table Yeah
we share it man okay it's a community
all right come on all right I like that
I like it do you have a preferred frozen
pizza now and when you were a kid
I mean obviously he's probably the
journal right when you were a kid you
were doing DiGiorno no I mean as a kid
they had those I mean you can go buy
them like the little five dollars yeah
little ilios or something you gotta
snatch that [ __ ] styrofoam I mean the
plastic wrap around there yeah it's
always been nasty to me though I never I
don't like frozen people oh really but
you'll entertain a DiGiorno yeah yeah
I'm some broke [ __ ] yeah
like two weeks ago Dude it was so
[ __ ] good yeah I think they're fancy
as [ __ ] it made my day self-rising crust
yeah oh then it was tombstones too shout
out to grew up on Tombstone now we're
talking
um but like I said we grew across the
street from the little season sure I
gotcha do you ever preferred Dorito
um
taco
Doritos y'all remember Taco flavor they
discontinued that too I know tacos
flavor I can't make this up
Taco Bell you think it's that crazy
chocolate flavored Doritos and I did I
used to like the pizza flavored ones too
back in the day oh I like pizza
whoa oh they got them out that's the
original that's the taco flavor oh
flavor damn damn they taste very
seasoned it tastes like I thought that I
thought they were just like I guess
regular tortilla chips I guess yeah
nacho cheese was there was this no Taco
flavor it says it on a sombrero so you
know it's true make a little note of
that they got them on Amazon
but yeah the Pizza flavor ones I think
David's doing that was a thing back then
they were doing sure sure damn okay
I want milk with the snacks okay what's
your if you had do you like Cheez-Its
you like combos she's like Pringles
cheeses are getting bizarre right now
man yeah they're going crazy store man
it's like dog what are y'all doing right
now
going crazy the white chat everything I
was at a gas station trying to get
regular [ __ ] and they don't have it
they don't have regular cheeses white
cheddar it's all this [ __ ] what are
we doing the ones that are kind of like
rigid though those are really good the
ones that are rigid yeah they like they
call them are they like that waved or
something like that yeah they're like
they're like they damn they're like a
Chex Mix yeah situation are you a Chex
Mix guy you like Chex Mix yeah yeah
that was always weird as a kid though
somebody like if somebody's aunt made
that at a party or like what the [ __ ]
what bacon Chex Mix yeah like homemade's
wonky give me like a pre-made that's
what we'll buy a company some ant with
some Aunt with no kids would make it be
like my favorite chip though is Monster
Munch the [ __ ] is this pickled onion
flavor monster It's a UK snack it's a
crisp monster Munch pickled oh pickled
onion so good oh I've seen these yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's so good so bad the
Brits on the low with the snacks thank
you okay and the candy is pretty wild
yeah in the pork and beans for breakfast
man is this are you a fan of that I just
can't imagine what school would be like
dude
baked beans and eggs goes together in a
weird way though I will say that I mean
I'm not hating on it I'm not hating on
it I'm just not gonna try it
um at the house do you keep your butter
on the counter in the fridge
I'm a fridge guy okay my girl she always
leaving the butter out on the counter is
that that's the white people shooting
classy
like I don't understand it it is I don't
know it's supposed to be out we've
learned she'd be pissed about that [ __ ]
like because she got like a whole butter
dish situation yeah she's like man put
the butter in the dish and I'm like man
come on man butter goes in the
refrigerator uh yeah I grew up with it
in the fridge but if they've learned it
is better to keep it out right you can
spread it oh on like it's classy to keep
it out okay I don't know what about the
peanut butter is that in the fridge or
out in the cabinet it's in the car for
the DUI Channel yeah exactly I don't eat
peanut butter though no no I'm not a
peanut butter guy okay where'd he keep
the ketchup
refrigerator okay you do a name brain
ketchup you're doing Heinz yeah I'm
pretty sure okay see she'd buy all the
condiments okay I just bought the meats
and [ __ ] okay I'm a hot sauce I'm a hot
sauce to the HEB it's the best place in
the world what's that HEB is this
groceries yeah I love it I just go to
HEB just to hang out sometime really
just walk around and [ __ ] I swear to God
it's amazing I love that place check it
out big on supermarkets I love this
place man I go there every I'm anytime I
can I'll go there you know what we like
down tomorrow we're in Tejas say it I
was about to ask him what do you think
of buckies oh yeah
all right it's like a redneck [ __ ]
7-Eleven I've been scared I'd be scared
any given turn like the KKK is about to
come out of here
something about it is be like I don't
know if is this it segregated I'll get
my kolache somewhere else thank you yeah
oh man
um the sleeping situation how many
pillows do you use
for one you have one pillow underneath
it and what yeah I got a big pillow
though you just have one pillow behind
your head you sleep on your side or on
your back on my side okay and no pillow
here no pillow between your legs my girl
she can take all I mean we have a lot of
pillows in the bed sure but she do
everything you say is messing around
yeah and then we got two chihuahuas so
they're in there they're sleeping in the
bed with us too oh that's all right
that's pretty clear one pillow um
Samsung can ditto Samsung and ditto okay
I like it respectable what um you got a
fan in the bedroom ceiling fan ceiling
fan that on when you go to sleep I don't
I don't prefer it to be but her ass
cause it's cold as [ __ ] that one thing
about Texas man is that it's so hot
everywhere you go it's [ __ ] freezing
because everybody got their [ __ ] air
conditioning room 50. yeah she's one of
those types you know the air
conditioners I'm [ __ ] freezing the
ceiling fan is going I'm sleeping every
night in the full [ __ ] jogging pants
sock songs
I will say I've been in recent time I'm
just not starting to get used to how
cold it is because even I have my
daughter come out and she she did not
have a good time because she's like so
cold in here Dad she's like give me a
blanket give me so she just sit in the
house all day like and then you go
outside it's [ __ ] 100 degrees so yeah
no I know that that's that switches a
lot how do you win you get that [ __ ] can
you get sick like that man yeah I know I
always get sick in the beginning of the
summer because I have the AC cranking
too hard but I love it I love sleeping
cold I have to ask for the quick a
bridge story at least of what did you
get locked up for
um selling drugs okay fair enough I mean
I but I I would say it wasn't the actual
selling drugs part that got that made me
get locked up it was I would catch a
whole bunch of like loitering tickets
sure and I would have but I would never
go to court for them so when they
finally like even when they caught me
and they put me on probation I wouldn't
say my probation officer one time left
like I'm smoking blunts what's she
talking about I ain't never coming back
so I violated probation off a rib I was
just one of those kind of guys so when
they finally got their hands on me like
oh yeah you got to go to jail been doing
this [ __ ] he was 13 years old like so
yeah like truant I had so many like
truancy from skipping schools tickets
and [ __ ] and I would hide them I
wouldn't tell my mom about it and you
know he's supposed to go to court and
all that [ __ ] I just never go to work
yeah I did eight months over that [ __ ]
damn yeah that's the longest you can do
in the county jail
it was it was it was fun it was like it
was like camp hanging out will you sleep
with the TV on
I want to my girl don't let me that's
classy
[Laughter]
I want to I like sleeping like you know
put sport [ __ ] on and go to sleep okay I
think I'm pretty good here ever been
attacked by an animal
I got bit by a dog okay that's normal I
feel normal about dogs bad bite bid bite
no no no
it bit my hand it just bit my hand
reaching a Pettit or something yeah yeah
oh I used to have Bengal cats that
attacked me all the time what the [ __ ]
a Bengal cat like a regular that's like
a house cat or like I mean they see
that's the thing about them they're like
domesticated jungles I don't know what
you're talking about people are mad that
they even exist they're [ __ ] vicious
yes they're vicious it's like a little
tiger yeah yeah so I had Bangles I had
two of them this thing yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
that defensive and it's expensive in
them and they hate your guts because
they're you know they're mad that
they're [ __ ] wait were they yours you
you had them me and my ex girl we took
out she the one took them so yeah damn
now I'm a dog guy now [ __ ] that what do
you got yeah
[Music]
I mean I will say reason why I'm a dog
guy like just recently we put um Ditto
in obedience school for like two weeks
why I had to go do some [ __ ] in Europe
and she went to Mexico and the dog came
back worse than it was before we put it
in but when I went to go pick her up you
know from the actual school just the
love that I felt like she jumped up
let me licking me on my face like what
the [ __ ] and my cash I would come home
from like a three-month tour they'll
just be looking at me like what's this
[ __ ] back yeah I thought he was gone
he'll be pissed hiding from me from days
I'm trying to be nice trying to get some
love they're like they don't give a [ __ ]
no I don't give a [ __ ]
bad but my Chihuahuas they love me I
can't wait to get home and see them love
that love it
what do you think Kip
I think he's [ __ ] trash
there's no other way around it you know
I mean the one Saving Grace he had is he
bought his mom a [ __ ] house which is
a pretty sweet Powerball or move I love
it he's got a license he don't know how
to drive I mean you know
your girl car that drives for him
because you don't know how to drive but
he tried to buy a license for five grand
but got away with it was a smile because
he had a grilling ladies and gentlemen
Mr Danny Brown there's a Danny Brown
Show at ymh Studios anything else you
want the folks out there to know you got
coming up I mean I got my album coming
out you know probably yeah sometime
I'm coming out soon love that check him
out on social check out his pod on ymh
fantastic buddy we love it man thanks so
much thank you guys for having me it's
fun thank you buddy what do you got uh
guys we're all over the road check out
our dates the link is in the description
shows they're selling out so get those
[ __ ] techies while you can we love
you see you next week peace